[Music]
Nickelodeon's the loud house is all
about life in a big family there are so
many characters that it can be hard to
keep them all straight well after this
video you won't be confused anymore are
you obsessed with all the hit shows on
TV
be sure to subscribe to keep up with all
the four one one on your favorite shows
now let's take a look at the characters
from the loud house
Lincoln loud the star of the show is
Lincoln loud he's the only boy in a
family of a lot of girls he's the middle
child as in smack-dab in the middle he
has five older sisters and five younger
ones Lincoln is 11 years old he's always
coming up with a new plan which usually
backfires he enjoys reading comics and
has a bunch of pets like Gio the hamster
and Walt the canary Lori loud Laurie is
the oldest sibling in the loud house
family at 17 she's obsessed with her
cell phone and her boyfriend Bobby she
can be really bossy but if you're the
oldest of 11 siblings you'd probably be
bossy to you even though she can be kind
of a dictator she loves all of her
younger siblings and they love her she
hates it when her siblings touch her
stuff we get it it must be hard to find
privacy in a family that big she's
overall an awesome big sister lynnie
loud after Lori comes lenny l loud
lynnie is sixteen years old and she's a
hilarious character Lenny just really
isn't that smart she's really ditzy but
she has some bad fashion skills she is
very sweet and her siblings would love
her even though they get annoyed at her
lack of smarts sometimes she's not very
responsible even though she's almost an
adult guys I still can't see open your
eyes
Luna loud the next log sibling is Luna
loud and she is a fan favorite Luna is
15 years old she's obsessed with rock
and roll and her idol is rock star Mix
wagger Luna can be wild and carefree
that she is also one of the kindest and
most responsible siblings she sometimes
talks with a British accent like Mick
swagger who which can get on her
siblings nerves Louie and loud up next
is Louie and loud she is 14 and she is
hilarious
she is the comedian of the loud family
it doesn't matter what type of humour it
is LuAnn loves it she enjoys playing
pranks and making terrible puns her
jokes often make her siblings roll their
eyes she's positive and always happy
which is why she's one of the most
popular loud sisters among fans Lynne
ell loud jr. the thirteen-year-old girl
is named after their father Lynne is a
total tomboy she is obsessed with all
sports and she's great at them too Lynne
is super competitive
she turns everything into a competition
that she wants to win which can irritate
her siblings she loves to roughhouse and
can be very immature at times
Lucy's out now let's talk about
Lincoln's younger sisters and she's kind
of the black sheep of the family she's
got a serious goth life and she's
obsessed with poetry and all things dark
she is gloomy and doesn't like to
socialize much she has a spooky habit of
popping up out of nowhere and scaring
her siblings on accident of course even
as weird as her siblings can be they
still think Lucy is really strange mana
loud Lana Elle loud is one of the twins
in the loud family she is six years old
and his two minutes older than her twin
Lola
Lana is a total tomboy she loves to fix
things and it's a skilled handy person
she loves to get dirty and is obsessed
with all things gross Lana is also a
huge animal lover she's often seen with
her pet frog hop
Lola loud Lola Lavis Lana's twin sister
and she couldn't be more different
at six years old Lola is obsessed with
all things pink and girly she is a
pageant queen and always wears a fancy
dress and a tiara she's spoiled and will
do anything to get her way
is a huge tattletale she's also very
vain she always checks her makeup in the
mirror she's got a nasty temper and
throws huge tantrums when she doesn't
get what she wants
very immature yep that's me mr. mature
Lisa loud the second-youngest loud
sibling is Lisa loud at four years old
she is a super genius she's always doing
advanced calculations or crazy science
experiments even though she's only in
kindergarten she is the smartest member
of the loud family she's got a huge ego
and she often plays pranks on her
siblings with her inventions genius or
not she's still just a kid who likes to
join in the craziness of her huge family
Lily loud the youngest member of the
loud family is Lily Elle loud she's only
15 months old she can walk but she can
speak much yet she's a really happy baby
and doesn't cry very often her only bad
habit is her dirty diapers which really
grosses out her older siblings but she
can't help it Lily is closest to Lincoln
Lenny and Luna but she's loved by all of
her siblings Lynne L out senior the
father of all the loud kids is Lynn L
out we don't know his exact age but he's
in his 40s Lynne can be very stern when
he needs to break up fights between his
kids but he's also the most sensitive of
the two parents he loves his kids and
his wife a lot he's a chef and loves to
cook even though he used to work in IT
he's a great dad to all of his children
read aloud read aloud is the mother of
all the loud kids and the wife of Lynn
senior she's a great mom she is very
caring but she is also never afraid to
be the disciplinarian when the kids act
up like her husband she is in her 40s
Rita works as a dental assistant and she
aspires to be a novelist of the two
parents Rita is the more level-headed
Clyde McBride
sure there are a lot of Louds but what
about the rest of the characters Clyde
McBride is Lincoln's best friend he is
11 years old and he's kind of nerdy he
worries a lot and can be really neurotic
he's an awesome friend and usually goes
along with Lincoln's crazy ideas Clyde
has two dads Howard and Harold Clyde is
toad
smitten for Laurie and his reactions to
her are hilarious what do you think of
pudding operation find our family and
get back at LuAnn for causing years of
emotional damage and also think of a
shorter name for this operation into
action
Ronnie Ann Santiago Lincoln's best
female friend and crush is Ronaldo and
Santiago or Ronnie Ann for short she's
11 years old and she is the toughest
girl in school she used to bully and
tease Lincoln but she says she only did
it because she had a crush on him
she was Lincoln's first kiss and she
also has a huge family Bobby Santiago
roberto alejandro martinez milan Luis
Santiago jr. is 17 years old the key is
Ronny hands older brother and most
importantly Lori's boyfriend he and Lori
talk all the time and are totally in
love Bobby works a lot of jobs but he's
usually pretty laid back and fun he's
the kind of big brother and he's nice to
all of Laurie's younger siblings - who
is your favorite character from the loud
house
let us know in the comments and that's
it for all the info about the characters
on the loud house check on our community
page for more content and don't forget
to subscribe
[Music]